بالكاد يمكنك أن تقول إن صاروخًا باليستيًا
أصاب صخرة قبل ساعات قليلة فقط ،
لكن العراقيين رأوها ، كل ما
يبدو أنه دورة واحدة لا نهاية لها من
الحرب التي عاشها محمد ، البالغ من العمر ثلاثين عامًا ،
خلال غزو أمريكي وحرب أهلية
وإرهاب القاعدة
وقد يكون لدى إيزيس جاكيمو ما بين العمر الذي انتقل
إليه وقد أظهرته ولم يترك أحدًا
نولان إذا رأيت intron كبير وستعرف Google
ما فعلته وحدة
الاتحاد لأنها تعرف أن الأب الذي شكلته عقود
من الحرب العراق الآن محاصر بينه
حليفان يواجهان مواجهة خطيرة
على أرضها سينما شابيرو
سارة أنا بيل آدمز ، نعم ، أيها
الموظفون الجدد الذين يمكن أن يكونوا آدمنا المتسرب من
كابريرا لم يفعلوا بدلاً من ذلك عند
أي الله ثم عصر هنا في وسط
بغداد عندما كنت  التحدث إلى الناس
يا بني يلومون إيران على الوضع الحالي ،
يلوم الآخرون الولايات المتحدة على هذا
التصعيد ، لكن الشيء الوحيد الذي
يتفق عليه الجميع تقريبًا أنهم يريدون
استبعاد العراق منه ، لكن منذ سنوات الآن ، أصبح
العراق مكانًا داميًا.  اندلعت حرب روكسي ،
هذه مافيا ، لا يوجد ديلارد
يخطئ في مقاطعة المارة ، نريد
أن يكون كل شخص سايروس وأن يغادر هذا البلد
والسلام ، أريد أن أربي حفيدي ،
لا أريد أن يموت ، نحن نعلم أن هذه
اللعبة نعرف  المتعلمون في العراق
لاحظوا أنها لعبة لكنها لعبة دفع
الكثير من العراقيين ثمنها بالفعل
جيمانا كراتشي سي إن إن بغداد